gerade hat china die elektroauto quote
eingeführt und noch mehr innovative
ideen kommen vor allem aus china
zwar gibt es dort auch den ein oder
anderen pfiff aber es zeigt sich dass
sich doch in china am meisten bewegt und
auch abseits dieser neuesten
technologien wird auf chinas straßen der
verkehr der zukunft geplant wie das dort
genau läuft welche entwicklungen geplant
sind und was wir uns von den chinesen in
sachen mobilität abrufen können und am
ende noch ein geschenk für euch jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
wer sich bei uns beispielsweise über den
täglichen stau im ruhrgebiet aufregt war
wohl noch nie auf den straßen in chinas
unterwegs die zustände dort sind
wirklich unvorstellbar katastrophal 2010
zb gab es rund um pc ein stau der
insgesamt mehr als 18 tage dauerte unter
den anhaltenden und täglichen
verkehrsprobleme in china leiden nicht
nur die menschen selbst 250 mikrogramm
feinstaub belastung sind hier keine
seltenheit dabei sind laut
weltgesundheitsorganisation bereits ein
zehntel davon also 25 mikrogramm
gesundheitsgefährdend die menschen in
peking haben alle eine app auf dem handy
die ihnen die aktuelle luftqualität
anzeigt und die ist wie gesagt mehr als
besorgniserregend der hoch ist kaum
auszuhalten er ist beißend und ätzend
zugleich über der ganzen stadt hängt
eine weltliche dunstglocke für die
olympischen spiele 2008 mussten deshalb
strenge verbote erlassen werden und
fabriken wurden für die zeit der spiele
geschlossen und danach wurde es nicht
besser man traut sich kaum einzuordnen
dieser zustand hat den peking übrigens
schon einen eigenen namen erpo calypso
und durch den smog gibt es am ende auch
tote es gibt schätzungen nach denen 1,6
millionen menschen pro jahr in china
durch diese luftverschmutzung einen
verfrühten tod sterben
kein wunder also dass die chinesen viele
innovative ideen bezüglich des verkehrs
der zukunft haben auf der
internationalen hightech messe in peking
wurde im mai vergangenen jahres das
verkehrsmittel der zukunft präsentiert
der tb der bi der trends survey bas ein
riesiger bus der über den staus aus den
autos unter ihm hinüber gleitet zudem
noch elektrisch angetrieben und somit
kein weiterer smog verstärker für chinas
straßen
einige verkehrsexperten weltweit und
auch viele medien waren im ti bier aus
endlich einmal ein unkonventionelles
mutiges und innovatives projekt was nach
meinung einiger experten auch für alle
anderen großstädte ein absolutes
must-have sei
doch wenig später dann die riesige
enttäuschung der tb ein riesiger bluff
die verantwortlichen sitzen wegen betrug
eine haftstrafe ab der prototyp ist
längst verrostet und die teststrecke
abgerissen medien
sehen einen umfassenden anlagebetrug
hinter der ganzen geschichte
doch die idee war ehrlich gesagt auch zu
schön um wahr zu sein auch eine weitere
innovative idee aus china wurde nie zur
realität eine neue spezies des autos
wurde uns versprochen der ewn ein team
an ein elektroauto als direkte
konkurrenz zu tesla durch seine 1050 ps
sollte der fv an laut plan in weniger
als 2 3 9 sekunden von 0 auf 100
stundenkilometer beschleunigen
die idee kam von dem amerikanischen
startup farideh future viel geld kam
zusätzlich vom vorsitzenden des
chinesischen elektronik konzerns liegt
die reichweite 600 kilometer möglich
gemacht durch lithium ionen batterien
mit 130 kilowattstunden 290.000 dollar
ein schnäppchen dachten sich offenbar
viele denn bereits 36 stunden nach der
präsentation gab es bereits rund 64.000
vorbestellung 2018 sollte das
elektroauto auf den markt kommen 5000
dollar musste jeder interessent direkt
an zahlen doch das ist mittlerweile mehr
als ungewiss denn das lazarett future
scheint auf sehr wackligen beinen zu
stehen sein großinvestor beispielsweise
scheint in zahlungsschwierigkeiten zu
stecken
auch für eine dritte idee die erst
einmal durch die decke schoss gab es ein
eher ernüchterndes ende zumindest bisher
der elektrische passagier multipler
haben 184 sollte laut plan 23 minuten in
der luft bleiben und in eine höhe von
rund drei kilometern kommen das ziel
sollte man einfach per app ansteuern
können ein kontrollzentrum sollte sich
um start flug und landung kümmern
in diesem juli sollten die lufttaxis an
den start gehen doch bis auf einige
geglückte testflüge gab es noch keine
erfolgsmeldung was aber erstmal noch
nicht so viel bedeutet drei
fallbeispiele aber auf jeden fall die
darauf hinweisen dass die ideen der
chinesischen entwickler und
entwicklerinnen super innovativ sind sie
diese allerdings nicht liefern können
zumindest nicht so schnell wie
angekündigt dabei ist china laut meinung
vieler forschungsteams tatsächlich das
land das die mobilität der zukunft wird
bestimmt zum einen weil china zur
technologie nation aufsteigen will aber
zum anderen auch aus der eigenen not
heraus die drei gescheiterten projekte
die ich bisher vorgestellt habe sehen
viele experten deswegen nicht als beweis
dafür an dass chinesisch
für ideen zum scheitern verurteilt sind
stattdessen sei dies ein indiz dafür
dass technik basierte innovationen aus
china in den letzten jahren stark
zugenommen haben unter anderem auch weil
die regierung start-ups aus der
privatwirtschaft unterstützt ein
wahrhaftiges prestige objekt aus china
allerdings ist die elektromobilität 2020
soll es mehr als fünf millionen
elektroautos auf chinas straßen geben
peking hat jetzt gerade ein gesetz
durchgebracht das den verkauf von
elektroautos sogar anordnen
autohersteller in china müssen bereits
in zwei jahren eine feste elektro quote
von 10 erfüllen oder aber als
strafzahlung leisten so produzieren
nicht nur die chinesischen automarkt
eifrig elektroautos auch audi bmw und
volkswagen stellen ihre modellpalette um
weltweit stammen rund 40 prozent aller
elektroautos aus chinesischer produktion
so eine studie von mckinsey 0,25 prozent
so hoch oder besser niedrig war in
diesem jahr die chance auf ein neues
nummernschild in peking in shanghai
dagegen laxey immerhin bei 4 prozent für
ein los musste man dafür aber rund
11.000 euro bezahlen je nach änderung
des nummernschilds gibt es zudem auch
festgelegte tage im monat in denen die
entsprechenden autos nicht gefahren
werden dürfen sondern abwechselnd in der
garage stehen müssen
ein ganz großes ding in china städten
ist die shared mobility hier wird also
geteilt busse autos und fahrräder und
das in einem ausmaß wie man es sich bei
uns kaum vorstellen kann 20 millionen
fahrten pro tag gehen auf das konto des
chinesischen pompons im vergleich dazu
aber kommt in new york pro tag auf
200.000 fahrten selbst wenn man
berücksichtigt dass mehr menschen in
peking als in new york leben ist ober
damit mehr als abgeschlagen und auch
fahrräder werden natürlich geteilt mit
dem handy wird es geortet und man umgeht
damit den stau für eine stunde hat man
umgerechnet 12 cent und dass das alles
sinn macht das ist mittlerweile auch in
den köpfen der chinesen angekommen es
gibt studien nach denen sich 40 prozent
der menschen dort vorstellen können sich
kein eigenes auto zu kaufen ja und jetzt
gibt es ein geschenk für euch wie
versprochen in zusammenarbeit mit der
redaktion von technology review einen
ganz fantastischen zeitschrift ist
dieses video entstanden und ecstasy
für pixum zuschauer habe ich jetzt eine
ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen link
klickt dann bekommt er sie ist lohnt
sich kann ich nur sagen der klassische
review ist wirklich mega spannend und
hier geht es zu einem weiteren video das
wir mit der reaktion gemacht haben 3d
druck revolutioniert die raumfahrt klick
drauf wenn es euch interessiert und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran